the Silver Lining is that when these
people go more hysterical and they
believe in censorship and they believe
in lies and they believe in all the
authoritarian uh policies that you can
possibly imagine what it does is it
takes good people
decent people maybe who aren't
completely driven by politics who
believe in other things who enjoy life
whatever that means to them and it
creates very strange bedfellows in
people so I am very proud of the clip
that I am about to show you here because
when I was on Bill Marshall about seven
eight months ago I said to him you gotta
have Gutfeld on the show because I think
you guys first off you're both late
night comedians now Gutfeld is now
number one at late night gutfeld's a
great dude obviously bill and I hit it
off despite the differences I said you
gotta have him on he said I'll think
about it I'll think about it and then
about two months later I got a call from
Bill's producer and he said hey can you
connect us with Gutfeld well Gutfeld was
on Bill Maher's podcast on Sunday and
here they are remember one is on Fox
News Right conservative scary Fox News
and one is liberal Bill Maher here they
are getting stoned and drunk talking
about the brutal effects of cancel
culture no I watched a rain man again I
thought it held up pretty well but again
you couldn't make it because like he
says the r word a million times yeah
that kind of stuff we're like in
kindergarten or we have to say peepee
and poo poo and r word well Animal House
I think Animal House still holds up but
you can you could not do that movie
especially in the in the nightclub scene
when you do you mind if you we dance
with your dates that whole thing would
never happen it would never happen
that's the first time I ever saw every
move it's every movie yeah it's every I
mean any movie made even 10 years ago
and there's something there that you you
if you really examine who you are you
probably are not offended at all we all
laughed at this stuff and it wasn't
terribly we know what something's
terribly offensive but when you hear it
now in 2023
you
hunch up because you know not because it
itself but because you know the reaction
will cause yes as trust me that's the
Silver Lining because that's how we beat
this thing we maybe don't beat it fully
by politics there are moments we can and
DeSantis is doing that whole blueprint
thing and all that that's just fine but
we beat it with these strange alliances
right we beat it by by Myanmar being
able to do our thing by Gutfeld and Mar
being able to do their thing whatever
you're doing in your life to bridge
those gaps and if all of the same people
keep doing that the machine will get
crazier and crazier it'll always ramp up
the crazy right Joy Reed has no way to
get out of the of the bottomless pit she
has put herself into uh Chuck
Scarborough can't get out the machine
will keep going they're all in on it too
deep they they have pushed it too far so
they cannot come back which is the damn
shame because for the years that all of
us were warning them guys can you just
not lie about everything could you just
not be so completely evil you can be
mostly evil but not completely but they
couldn't listen so what they are going
to do is and this is My Hope and I
believe it can happen in 2024 at a
political level but it will first take
the it will take the personal and
cultural level first
we can have the most incredible Alliance
forming right now of those ex-libs and
the Libertarians and the conservatives
and the religious people and we can put
together something under the banner of
freedom
foreign
[Music]